Canada has a lot of oil and gas but to
get it to international markets it needs
pipelines lots of pipelines it's not
just Keystone XL that could carry oil
from the Alberta tar sands line 9 is an
outdated 38 year old pipeline that would
pump oil through the most populated and
water-rich parts of Canada Enbridge
northern gateway would carry oil to the
Pacific Chevron specific trails and
TransCanada's coastal gas link pipeline
would do the same with natural gas and
energy East would pump oil from Alberta
all the way to the Atlantic but the race
to build pipelines faces another
challenge blockade eeeh
environmentalists and the indigenous
resistance movements are challenging
these and many other pipelines using
courts government consultation and
on-the-ground blockades want more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your app store
now